hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so we're gonna talk about in
this video is how to use the product
rule so when you're taking a derivative
how do you know when to use the product
rule and how do you use it well we've
got a formula over here it's when you
have two quantities okay that are
actually multiplied together so product
means times or multiply and what you do
is you take the derivative of the first
quantity we're calling that you and you
can see the prime just means we're
taking the derivative of U times V okay
so we're leaving the second quantity
alone then we're adding and then we're
taking the first quantity leaving that
one alone but multiplying it by the
derivative of the second quantity sounds
complicated but it's a lot easier in
practice so let me see if I can show you
some examples so here what we're going
to do is we're going to think of this 5x
as ru and we're going to think of the
sign X as V and you can see they're
multiplied together because they're
right next to each other with nothing in
between right so we're gonna take the
derivative of U okay which equals five
okay because this is derivative X is
just 1 times 5 is 5 and we're going to
leave the sign X alone okay now we're
going to reverse it we're going to leave
you alone which is 5x but we're going to
take the derivative of sine of X which
is cosine X and that's it that's your
derivative now sometimes some books and
some teachers and some students they'll
do it actually you know in the reverse
way and that's completely fine they'll
leave the first one alone take the
derivative and then over here vice versa
so I just think of it in that fashion I
just think of I'm taking the derivative
one leaving the other one alone and then
I reverse it so I do the opposite which
ever want to take the derivative first
time I leave that one alone and take the
derivative the other one okay and then
you add them together okay so don't get
confused by you know some books are
slightly different
ok the next example we've got 7x squared
times cosine X let's just call this U
let's just call this V so we're going to
take the derivative 7x squared okay
we're gonna use our power ruler and
bring down the 2 multiply it by the 7
that's 14 and we're going to subtract 1
from the exponent so that's going to be
14 X to the first okay we're gonna leave
the cosine alone cosine X plus now we're
gonna reverse it we're going to
the 7x squared alone and we're going to
take the derivative of the cosine X
which is negative sine of X okay so some
of these are gonna have to start
memorizing as you go through calculus to
make it easier so derivative of sine is
cosine derivative cosine is negative
sine and then what we can do is we can
you know the positive in the negative
that's just could become minus 7x
squared sine X so we can kind of clean
it up or condense it a little bit so
that's your derivative
okay last example we've got the
derivative of 2x squared plus 3x that
quantity times 5x plus 1 now you're
probably thinking yourself Mario can I
just like file that out and then just do
the the power rule well you can but
sometimes when you're doing calculus
problems all you really need to do is
find the slope of the tangent line at a
specific point you might not want to you
know go through all that process of
simplifying taking the derivative just
to find the slope say well let's just
work with what I have here and then I
can substitute in my x value to find a
slope at that point so basically what
I'm trying to say is that it's not
always necessary to simplify first you
could just go ahead and say let's take
this first quantity call that you the
second quantity V there multiplied
together we're taking the derivative
we're gonna use our product rule because
they're multiplied right so the
derivative of this whole quantity 2x
squared plus 3x is going to be what it's
4x because we're bringing down the 2 2
times 2 is 4 we're subtracting 1 plus
bring down the 1 1 times 3 is 3x to the
0 is 1 so this just becomes 3 okay so we
took the derivative of U we're gonna
leave V alone
which is 5x plus 1 now we're going to
reverse it we're going to leave the
first quantity alone which is the 2x
squared plus 3x and we're going to take
the derivative the second quantity which
is derivative 5x we bring down the 1
that's 5 if we subtract 1 from the
exponent at 0 anything to the 0 is 1 so
that's just going to become 5 and then
the derivative of a constant of 1 is
just 0 so this just becomes 5 so that's
it so that's your derivative and you can
then use it at that point if you want to
you can simplify but it's not
necessarily you know necessary if you're
doing some additional steps to your
problem this is just a quick way to take
the derivative using the product rule so
I hope this video helped you subscribe
to the channel
check out some of my other videos and
I'll see you in the next video I'll talk
to you soon